this was the loudest largest and most
powerful rocket ever launched
SpaceX Starship hefted skywards by the
super heavy booster with thrust
equivalent to more than 100 jetliners at
takeoff booster after chamber pressures
Engineers that said just getting off the
launch pad would make this uncrewed test
a success the Houston tracking station
now acquiring the vehicle they got a lot
further than that onboard view from
Starship but Starship failed to separate
from its booster the rocket tumbling
through the atmosphere before breaking
apart
and the gung-ho fail fast world of Elon
musk's SpaceX
this moment was met by cheers
while the excitement will simply put
Starship is the largest rocket anyone
has ever built
the space shuttle was around 60 meters
tall with a 29 tonne capacity NASA's
latest Moon rocket SLS block one is a
whopping 98 meters tall Saturn V the
last rocket to go to the moon was bigger
and more powerful still but Starship
bolted on to the heavy booster dwarfs
even that at 120 meters with a 150 tonne
payload capacity but size isn't
everything
thank you
SpaceX dominates the commercial launch
market by making its Rockets reusable
Starship is designed to be the same
Elon Musk didn't look delighted Starship
was supposed to complete an orbit of
Earth before crashing into the sea but
even his critics were impressed by
today's result for a first test launch
of a completely new uh revolutionary
design like this I I'm I'm very happy
with it and I'm sure SpaceX will be too
the point is where when will it get into
space when will it get into orbit and
the Really revolutionary thing about
Starship is the idea of recovering for
reuse and so they're a long way off
SpaceX has proved it learns from its
failures but there'll likely be more
before Starship is ready for astronauts
Bound for the moon and Beyond Tom Clark
Sky News